معنا من بغداد دكتور احمد الصحافي المتحدث
الرسمي باسم وزاره الخارجيه العراقيه اهلا
بك معنا دكتور في هذه التغطيه كم عدد
الذين عادوا اذا تؤكد الرقم الذي ورد على
لسان احد افراد الجاليه من الذين عادوا او
العدد اكبر
تحيه وتقدير لحضراتكم العدد الذي احصيناه
بشكل دقيق هو
من افراد الجاليه العراقيه كان من دينهم
سته عشر مواطن من الدرس
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه
اذا نحن نتحدث عن مئتين واربعه عراقيا من
يعني من الذين عادوا من الذين احصيتموهم
16 مواطنا سوريا بينهم عدد العالقين حتى
الان هل تمكنتم من احصائهم
نحن وجهنا نداء عاجلا لابناء الجاليه
العراقيه الكريمه وحددها توقيتات ومواقع
محدده للانطلاق وصولا الى النقطه النهائيه
التي منها وهو مطار السودان
وبعض العراقيين افراد جدا محدودين لم
يتمكنوا من الوصول بسبب عدم
وسائل النقل من جهه ومن جهه اخرى الوضع
الامني الذي اعاقهم عن الخروج من مساكنهم
والتوجه الى الموقع النهائي للاجلاء لكننا
بالتاكيد مستمرون بتلقي الاتصالات
والاستجابه لمناشداتهم والعمل جارد في
غرفه
الاستجابه الدبلوماسيه الطارئه لتحقيق
استجابه ممكنه لهم
من داخل كيف تفعلون ذلك بمساعده دول اخرى
مثلا او او عبر اي قواعد ومطارات ابدا
الجهود عراقيه صرفه وبالتعاون مع السلطات
المعنيه في السودان هذه الرحله التي كانت
من الاجلاء كانت في الحقيقه بجهود عراقيه
تامه الطبابه العسكريه
وطائرات النقل الجوي العسكري وجهود وزاره
الخارجيه العراقيه للتنسيق مع سفاره
السودان في بغداد
والتنسيق والتعامل مع الجهات على الارض
هناك كلها ادت الى انجاح عمليه الاجلاء
التي اع عنها وطالعناها جميعا معكم والان
بالنسبه الى العالقين اذا كان هناك اعداد
لا تزال تريد العوده ماذا عليها ان تفعل
لا نزال نتصل بهم بشكل مباشر وننسق مع
السلطات المعنيه هناك كما اننا نجري الان
لمجموعه من الخيارات
الاستجابه الدبلوماسيه الطارئه ونلصق مع
الجهات المعنيه في الحكومه العراقيه
لتحقيق استجابه ممكنه خلال وقت العجل هل
كان هناك لا سمح الله قتله او جرح من
الجاليه العراقيه في السودان
سبق لنا ان اعلنا ان مواطن عراقيا واحدا
من ابناء الجاليه كان قد لقي حتفه
باطلاقها مصاص جراء الاشتباكات التي لا
تزال مستمر في السودان
الرسمي وحدده هويه المواطن العراقي
ولا نزال
نبحث عن اي معلومه تؤكد ان اعداد الاخرى
تعرضت الى ضرر لكن لم يتاكد لتقارير
الرسميه سوى ان هذا المواطن العراقي هو
الذي لقي حتفه اذا نحن نؤكد فقط
مصرع مواطن عراقي واحد ولم وهناك تقارير
عن يعني قد يكون هناك اصابات او قتل اخرين
ولكن ليس لديكم معلومات مؤكده حتى الان
كما افدتنا
انا قلت بالتحديد مواطن عراقي واحد لقي
حذفه ولم يتاكد لدينا باي تقارير رسميه
اخرى غير ذلك وانا اقول بعد ما كلامك انقل
عنك على لسانك بانه هذا الكلام غير مؤكد
هناك تقارير ولكن انتم غير متاكدين منه
طيب بخصوص من تبقى هناك هل تعرفون اماكن
تواجدهم هل هم في اماكن مثلا خطيره حتى
الان او في اماكن بعيده ولكن تقطعت بهم
سبل او ماذا
القسم الاغلب منهم يتواجدون في مناطق ليست
خطره لكنها نائيه وهذا ما اعاقهم في ان
يستقلوا وسائل
للتواصل
والاتصال وكذلك خطوط للنقل توصلهم الى
مطار بورد سودان نعمل الان على تحقيق
استجابه ممكنه من اجل التعرف على كامل
اعدادهم وتوفير ما يمكن لهم من اجل امنهم
وسلامتهم لكن المؤكد ان كل الذين رغبوا
بالاجلاء تم اجلائهم خلال الرحله التي
نفذت هذا اليوم
بخصوص الدبلوماسيين دكتور
العدد الكامل لطاقم سفاره جمهوريه العراق
في الخرطوم ولم يتبقى احد وبموجي بذلك اذا
ما قررنا ان نستجيب لاي مناشدات اخرى
فسنقوم
بتدابير لوجستيه من نوع معين لتحقيق هذه
الاستجابه هل تعرضت ايات مصالح عراقيه في
في السودان في هذه الحرب
يعني للاصابه للخطر السفاره القنصليات
المصالح شركات ما
التمثيل الدبلوماسي العراقي تمثيل مقيم
ومستقر في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
ونتيجه للاحداث والاشتباكات الجاريه الان
بين طرفين نزاع الان اجلي العدد الكامل
لطاقم السفاره الجمهوريه العراق
ومصالحنا هي تتمثل بالحفاظ على العلاقات
الثنائيه وهذا امر
مستدام ونعمل على تاكيده واصدرت الخارجيه
العراقيه بيانها الذي افادت بمضمونه دعوه
الطرفين نزاع الى اهميه الارتكان لطاوله
الحوار والعراق لن يدخر جهدا في تقديم اي
دعم وعون ومساعده فضلا عن الانضمام لايه
مبادرات من شانها ان تحد من اطلاق النار
وتنتهي بالصراع الجاري الى توافق وطني
سوداني يعزز الامن والاستقرار والسياده في
السودان شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور احمد الصحافه
المتحدث الرسمي باسمي وزاره الخارجيه
العراقيه من بغداد تحياتي اليك لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات